dans l'actualité également l'hypothèse
d'une fusion des deux départements
alsaciens qui ressurgissent c'est l'une
des pistes du mont rapport aux marques
ce mise en ligne hier sur le site de la
préfecture sur l'avenir institutionnel
de l'alsace documents que vous avez
consulté sylvie malal bonsoir à quoi
pourrait ressembler l'entité alsace
imaginé par le préfet alors le premier
enseignement c'est que l'état a pris
acte de l'importance des symboles
l'alsace c'est à dire les alsaciens et
pas seulement les élus ont exprimé le
besoin d'être réhabilités en tant que
tel c'est le désir balsa c'est ça ça a
été entendu ensuite il y à quatre
pistons pour ce statut
quatre pistes une institue une
institution de coopération
interdépartementale c'est le scénario a
minima un syndicat mixte un grand
département qui serait le résultat de la
fusion du haut-rhin et du bas-rhin ou
une collectivité à statut particulier et
c'est la troisième voie qui à la faveur
du préfet mais aussi du premier ministre
edouard philippe qu'il a écrit c'est ce
qu'il a écrit dans une lettre adressée
aux parlementaires et donc pas ce statut
particulier que beaucoup attendait ici
pourquoi parce que c'est un statut qui
fait peur une organisation porteuse de
risques selon les mots du premier
ministre alors plutôt que de voir
l'alsace comme une entité isolée elle
doit être un trait d'union dans l'espace
rhénan avec des compétences élargies et
ça ça va être possible grâce à la
réforme de la constitution
mais avec un préalable qui n'est pas
négociable pour le coup celui là tout ça
doit se faire à l'intérieur de la région
grand est et il n'est pas question d'en
sortir
alors qu'en pensent les élus alsaciens
estime-t-il que c'est une victoire dans
leur combat pour se démarquer le contest
a de façon très diplomatique
oui il salue une avancée il faut malgré
tout lire entre les lignes
les deux présidents de départements qui
ont initié le processus n'ont pas obtenu
le feu vert pour leur collectivité
d'alsace statut particulier cependant la
future entité c'est vrai on aura plus de
poids et plus de compétences quant au
président de la région grand est jean
rottner il évoque une réponse équilibrée
et c'est vrai que là le périmètre de la
région grand est ce ne va pas à bouger
mais il faudra transférer certaines
compétences à la aukeran départements
alsaciens et ça c'est la phase de
concertation qui va s'ouvrir quels
domaines justement pourraient être
concernés
la gestion des flux transfrontaliers le
tourisme et l'attractivité de l'alsace
l'attractivité qui peut éventuellement
englober l'économie l'enseignement et
notamment le bilinguisme pour lequel le
département de moselle pourrait être
associé et puis la culture il s'agit
donc selon le préfet d'un vrai projet de
territoire mais donc rien n'est encore
tranché
qu'en est il pour la suite une nouvelle
phase de concertation qui va s'ouvrir
qui va être menée par jacqueline
gourault ministre auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur le gouvernement pourrait
trancher de façon définitive en octobre
puisque de toute façon les élus veulent
aller vite les élections régionales et
départementales se profile pour 2021
donc si l'on fait un compte à rebours 1
vous le voyez on se rend compte que le
calendrier est très serré surtout avec
une réforme constitutionnelle qui a été
reporté alors sinon beaucoup plus simple
et plus rapide ça serait la collectivité
à statut particulier et brigitte
klinkert la président du haut rhin que
j'ai eu tout à l'heure au téléphone
affirmé qu une simple loi suffirait à la
créer mais on l'a vu ce n'est pas
l'option qui est retenue pour l'instant
dossier à suivre encore donc on l'aura
compris merci à vous si lui en sport